welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss an Avengers Secret Wars promises to
be the ultimate culmination of Marvel's
Multiverse Saga with everybody expected
to play some role from the current
Avengers lineup and Kang two returns by
Robert Downey Jr Tony Stark Hugh Jackman
Wolverine the spider triplets from no
way home and who knows maybe even the
best of us morbius no but really the
first real sign that secret Wars was the
game plan came and Doctor Strange in the
Multiverse of Madness with the A3
universe's Illuminati and Reed Richard's
warning of incursions including us into
what fan casted Ultra Universe Avengers
could look like and though many
overlooked it in recent weeks concept
art for Multiverse of Madness finally
released confirming much of what we
speculated could be Marvel's future
plans for More Heroes ahead of Secret
Wars leading us to wonder will Marvel
Studios end Secret Wars with a selected
multiversal reboot of the Marvel
characters and cast parents we most want
to see like a new Tony Stark a new
t'challa Miles Morales mutants Dr Doom
and more and a reminder to please
subscribe to new Rockstar's new spin-off
Channel The Deep dive in addition to
continuing making videos over here I'm
working on some new exciting side
projects over there and we'd love to
have you subscribe for it before we
launch February 17th okay in December
2022 one of the concepts storyboard
artists working on Doctor Strange the
Multiverse of Mattis Soren bent released
a series of fascinated pieces of concept
art for the film revealing the alternate
ideas being considered for the a38
universe Illuminati lineup this included
an image of Captain Carter with balder
the brave plus an iron monger variant or
perhaps Steve Rogers from what if and
Hydra stomper Armor after Hagee found
him in that would have season finale and
then of course Captain Marvel Maria
Rambo Boulder the brave is the
half-brother to Thor another son of Odin
an epic demigod as guardian Warrior
originally planned to be introduced in
Thor the Dark World alongside the
Warriors 3. his weakness is mistletoe
he's awesome and most recently he
speculated to be played by Daniel Craig
in Multiverse of Madness actually Daniel
Craig was recently asked about this role
by Josh Horowitz and Craig's response
was interesting to say the least have
you ever heard of the character balder
the brave
no there was a report Daniel that you
were going to be in Doctor Strange
don't you hide behind that mug Daniel
Craig
I don't know what you're talking about
[Laughter]
in theory would it be interesting to be
in a Marvel movie oh I'm taking a joke
I'm good I'm just like if the hours are
good I'd take any job how many of course
um sure absolutely yeah definitely okay
yeah
he's good he's too good for me damn it
um yeah I'm pretty sure Daniel Craig
suited up for at least a screen test or
the very least was in talks to do this
and based on his coiness here I am
wondering if Marvel Studios might have
held off and now plans to introduce him
in Avengers Kang Dynasty or Avengers
Secret Wars or some kind of spin-off
with Hercules but this concept art
lineup is posed in the Baxter Foundation
Lobby the set that was based on the
layout of the British museum in London
so this must have been from a version of
the movie that was fairly late in
production now lots of people spend
January trying to keep up with some kind
of self-improvement resolution going to
the gym eating better spending more time
at the gamma ray Salon to get that green
hulky glow you know the normal stuff but
for some of us we're happy with how we
are we just want to keep what we got and
that's what keeps us for Keeps offers
clinically proven research-backed
treatments to stop hair loss and improve
hair growth two out of three guys will
experience hair loss by the time they're
35 but with keeps you can get quality
expert care without ever visiting the
doctor's office or Pharmacy all keeps
treatment plans are recommended by a
licensed medical provider and delivered
straight to your door at about half the
cost of a traditional Pharmacy each
treatment plan comes with a full year of
unlimited messaging so you can connect
with your medical provider about
anything anytime keeps has a network of
Expert Medical advisors prescribers and
Care Specialists to support you in
making your hair goals a reality whether
you're looking to prevent hair loss
stimulate hair growth or just take
better care of the hair that you have
keeps as you covered hair loss stops
with keeps to get 50 off your first
order go to keeps.com new rockstars or
click the link in the description that's
keps.com new rockstars more concept art
shows man thing who of course was the
truth in live action and werewolf by
night and doctor strange fight in a
version of the villain nightmare in a
sorcerer battle and then this really odd
cell of Professor Xavier with an arrow
labeled mantis still trying to figure
out what this would be in reference to
but maybe Professor X's telepathy
abilities are linked with or crosswired
with mantises empath abilities with
mantis speed another alternate of the
a38 Illuminati which in that case it
would be interesting that they would
have someone not from Earth but these
images give us a lot of ideas for who
could have occupied that 7th empty see
it on the Deus of the A380 Illuminati my
top candidates have been a variant black
panther or not more and now balder the
Brave and to be clear I do not think
this seat belonged to 838 Stephen
Strange because 838 mordo took his
sorcerer Supreme spot in that center
chair and I don't think they would leave
out an empty seat to pay respects to a
guy who betrayed their trust their
statue out front they made clear was a
public-facing tribute to hide the dark
truth about what a3h strange did in case
you forgot a3h strange killed trillions
of people in Another Universe trillions
with a truck but we're starting to get a
sense of what Marvel Studios has in
plans for the biggest title on their
slate Avengers Secret Wars because
Multiverse of Madness will ever hate the
second act of that movie was 100 the
studio planting seeds for that event
Patrick Stewart Charles and Xavier John
Krasinski Reed Richards Anson Mount
blackbold Haley Atwell Captain Carter
Lashana Lynch Captain Marvel this was
the studio flexing some casting muscle
and offering a tease of what they have
in mind for Secret Wars like if they
could get Stewart and Krasinski on the
call sheet they can get anyone and
clearly that's their case going forward
with Hugh Jackman returning his
Wolverine and Deadpool 3 there's
actually some unconfirmed rumors going
around that Jackman might be signing a
two movie deal now that has not been
verified yet but I think we can all read
the tea leaves and see an MCU crossover
in Deadpool 3 make some Wolverine Cameo
and Adventure Secret Wars even likelier
there's also some buzz in the scoop Loop
that Robert Downey Jr is returning as
Tony Stark in secret Wars though I don't
think that comes as much of a shocker to
anyone but what does it say about a
future MCU crossover event that what
excites fans most about it aren't who
from the current roster of MCU Heroes
will be most pivotal to the plot but
really which old faces might get pulled
out of retirement for One Last Ride of
the new Heroes introduced in phase four
we still don't really know who the
Avengers are right now is that a bad are
you in a band like obviously it's some
mix of Wong Captain Marvel Hulk and
shung Chi because we're the only time we
saw the Avengers Assemble in phase four
was in that shung chibo's credit scene
we also gotta assume roady's part of the
lineup and yeah probably also includes
Sam Wilson and She-Hulk Monica Rambo
Kamala Khan K Bishop Cassie Lang and
iron heart ReRe will you meanwhile Thor
Dr Strange Peter Barker they all seem to
be doing their own thing Moon Knight
werewolf by night man thing Daredevil
white vision and others are probably in
the mix but we don't really know where
in the mix they are yet and then we also
got just a bunch of kids a lot of them
played by young actors who seem to be
confused as hell as to what VFX artists
are being forced to do to them but we do
know the big bad of all this Kang the
Conqueror and I believe that through
this villain and the way his dynasty
assembled their empire from across
timelines and across the universes
Marvel Studios is laying the groundwork
to Prime viewers for an across-the-board
selective reboot of all of their Heroes
after Secret Wars some Heroes will stay
While others will go back into
retirement and get recasts with variants
played by big name actors who we all
love and that will leave the primary
universe of the MCU complete with one
clear lineup of the primary Marvel
heroes and villains and yeah I think
that includes a new Iron Man Tony Stark
a new Wolverine and other new X-Men a
live-action Miles Morales a new adult
t'challa black panther really anyone won
the studio wants to be part of their
lineup to best support the current mix
that from what we could tell it really
just seems to be Wong doing his best to
keep things from falling apart like this
is just my side hot take right now but I
think one move Marvel could have pulled
after Avengers end game would have been
a post-credits scene in which Tony
Stark's death was being viewed on
another universe's Illuminati video
screen as Reed Richards turns to an
alternate recast Tony Stark to say work
with us and this will never happen to
you they wouldn't even need to recast
for the new actor yet just show a
superior Iron Man helmet and then mix in
that sound effect with Iron Man Repulsor
warm-up now obviously they didn't do
something like this since the end game
was difficult enough to pull off and
they wanted it to be a climactic
send-off to one era and give themselves
time to move on and to test out some new
Heroes and then also have a couple
follow-up phases to bring back anyone
from the Multiverse animate account but
to say the MCU can never have a Tony
Stark in it ever again unless we come up
with some wild crossover plot once per
decade to get Robert Downey Jr to come
back would be like saying we're gonna
have a DC Universe with no Batman in it
like saying haven't we all had enough
Batman no we haven't all had the Batman
just like no we haven't all had enough
Tony Stark it's not enough just to have
a few Vigilantes to remind us of Batman
just like let's have all the cool
Engineers that Tony Stark inspired and a
Tony Stark so I think that's gotta be
the true secret agenda behind Avengers
Secret Wars to blow everything up to get
everyone who's ever played a Marvel
anything in a movie together and then to
pick and choose who stays and who gets
recast to give the MCU its ideal lineup
of Avengers spideys X-Men Fantastic Four
Thunderbolts midnight Sons Young
Avengers and all of our favorite
villains including Dr Doom and Galactus
let me know your thoughts would you
really be okay with a recast to Tony
Stark I mean I know you're gonna say
that Robert Downey Jr feels like the
only definitive Tony Stark ever but you
know we also used to feel that way about
like Michael Keaton Batman I'm Batman
also again please please please
pre-subscribe to new Rockstar's new
channel the Deep dive it is launching
February 17th that will be the place
that I will be digging even deeper into
a few select titles with a more pointed
investigatory Focus Channel handle and
on all socials at Deep dive NR you can
also follow me on Instagram and Twitter
at EA boss follow new Rockstar subscribe
to new rock rockstars or breakdowns and
theories of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
[Music]